hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play dead
space okay I'm all set from last time I
actually had to restart chapter 5 just
to get back far enough to get to a point
where I would be okay now a couple
things have changed I upgraded my guns
and I upgraded my suits and actually
learned to create items from the bench
which admittedly took me longer than it
was supposed to buy whatever my gamer
cred was in question ergo I had to try
hard try real hard anyway I'm back a bit
farther than I was before but not too
far I am just about to unleash to think
because when I get back to my save I
couldn't get away from him long enough
to get to a fence so I had to go back
but anyway I am back and I'm willing to
strive to survive lose your [ __ ] and
also I finally have the evangelizer gun
which means that I will be I finally
have a capable machine gun and not
whatever the
for one or I can still suck but whatever
dogged dogged breath it's all good bread
hi hey what do you think you're doing
tickling me
I also crafted a bunch of med kits so
that should put me a little better than
I was
hey buddy say bye to your legs alright
so this is about where I was before as I
was trying to run and survive I just
need to get here long enough so that I
can call the tram yeah I finally got
this uh this evangelizer weapon which is
much much better I like it a lot it has
a very very capable shotgun and
everything else and so long as two of
the bastards don't spawn wait you're
still alive well I should be fine hi hi
yeah the shotgun actually can
effectively knock this [ __ ] down whoa
hold your horses there and it actually
does a considerable amount of damage
which is important to me I just got to
watch my back it's what I really got to
watch how about it hey look my back huh
Bruce ha Bisky thank you nice they're
actually giving me med kits now uh no he
it down the tram will arrive
thank you okay yeah there are two of
them I was not mistaken there are
actually two of them thank you here's me
well hello
hi I don't know why there are two of
them but there are sit down I can knock
him down from across the room is that
the tram I see I do believe it is okay
trams here let's go come on now no time
to waste
get No Go Go Go Go there weren't that
many of them before okay now there are
two admitted to the tram
looks like it stops at the mid and aft
station the a stations where the shuttle
is parked and what about miss station
well that would be the conning tower
okay now this is interesting
records indicate a number of useful
tools and salvage were signed out from
storage there by a lieutenant Tucker
Edwards could be worth a look alright
if I check it out I'll let you know
Isaac out
we got another optional mission on the
road so let's go check it out
mind your head mind your head I like
this gun a lot this gun is very very
much nicer than my last guns you guys
weren't kidding I don't know why I
didn't try it or didn't get to do it
sooner okay
here's another puzzle yay alright okay
and there we go huh
hahaha and this is oh boy oh lordy come
on oh boy this is not as easy as it
looks it's takes some wonky coordination
but they seem to be doing okay and just
like that bingo Bongo got it gotta go
see you after I actually understand what
it wants from me I can get it a little
better also I made a torque bar I did I
did make a torque bar as you guys tell
me the bench is my best friend and I
need to be okay with that I wasn't
before but now I am and now I'm in it to
win it
uh-huh uh-huh scenario fob that's pretty
morbid they have to kill kill themselves
I'm guessing yeah sorry I'm not sticking
around for a lot of the messages I got
to get through the game yes you were
smart enough to make me guys my lockout
okay yeah goon squad but before you go
patting yourself on the back
no that was the Oh about to get a whole
lot worse whoa hi buddies you want to
get down from there dick okay how is
there someone on this ship I thought
this whole situation is like these
a-holes are this whole base is 200 years
old isn't it at least that's what my
assumption was hey nope
shotgun I love this gun now this is what
I'm talking about this is always what I
had in mind a proper machine gun for
safe keeping you can put a bullet in my
down
but I've got a ready-made army that says
you can and oh yeah the Dodge I need to
work cuz control is not a convenient
thing to Dodge
I can't they be one of the mouse buttons
now whatever what's up here I'll find
out later hey either way I am much more
coordinate coordinated now and yes I am
still playing on hard I did not change
the difficulty in case any of you were
wondering how you do it better
he musta cheated somehow no I did not I
just suddenly got promoted engaged hey
screw you dick oh I see he unlocked all
of the ventilation shaft
whoa what I where you come from what the
[ __ ] where do you come from I was trying
to shoot you
you're killing me Oh rip your freaking
head off Wow I need better rate of fire
on that Oh a freakin destroyed him come
here [ __ ] thank you
also I upgrade my Kinesis haha stab him
in the face I upgrade my Kinesis a bit
so that I can finally think this are
actually working actually noticed after
I did that my um Kinesis module is
actually pulling blades and not random
objects which i am so much happier about
basically everything is actually working
as it should shut up
Wow where the [ __ ] did you come from
what the hell get off of me a hole these
guys are either are you not you too it's
not pile on Isaac day get off of me
[ __ ] you're like halfway to death how
do you get back up man he's gotta know
oh [ __ ] I'm out of shotgun come on there
we go there we go
cuz now I can strategically dismember
him the way I always dreamed I could
still more
who's out there oh no you do not he's
dead
I thought he was dead maybe he's not
dead oh no there's another one down here
miss maid dick Wow I thought this corner
might have been a little safe apparently
it is not and I need to get the hell out
of here like the items oh look at him
crawling up no no no no no kiss me I
think I can actually catch those
projectiles and throw them back if I was
a bit more skilled and pro warning
contamination detect okay so I got a
breather here I can actually do this
okay good no one better sneak up on me I
might get angry and you won't like me
when I'm angry
no one asks me when I'm angry except my
fans because they love to watch me
scream and rage sir I'm so angry
ah please my magic card is superior
Isaac Clarke always angry whoa what the
hell
Wow hey hold your horses there [ __ ] oh
that is so fricking awesome I call this
the room sweeper yep but that Arsenal
you are they gonna help you now
electricity wait that didn't say that
that said you can't shoot what you can't
see what about what but I got this
stasis module that usually helps me with
electrical tap situation buckle Edward
just brings some kind of electrical
traffic looks like a homemade job with a
short-range transmitter in a rainy John
got it hahahaha God
oh hello
just a few bullets and come on my burner
hey why can you go through through that
Hey wah-wah boom thank you
I'm letting them get too close I'm
getting a little cocky with this gun
here I shouldn't just I should stop
being so silly next we just get to
business remember that I got a job to do
Oh perfect I'm the man I'm gonna stab
this [ __ ] in the face duh how's it
Clark gonna stab you in the eyeballs
there we go
lotta somatic gel which is what I need
for med kit so I should be good so mad a
gel some gel cargo lift oh I get it okay
one second let me just see this another
upgrade Oh Booya reload and clip I like
the combo ones combo ones is good I
don't want to apologize because I made a
lot of rash criticisms about the game
when I should have been I'm usually a
lot more fair about the game and I just
I was it was my fault that I was doing
poorly it was all my fault
no problem with this the design of the
game I was complaining about my weapons
being weak when my weapons are weren't
upgraded I was complaining about
Canisius not working properly when my
Kinesis wasn't upgraded I was
complaining about dying quickly when my
armor wasn't upgraded it was all my
fault my criticisms were incorrect in
that one and I apologize I try to be
more fair than that a lot I let my anger
yes
it's like I'm gonna get the best of
these Necromorphs from now on yeah duh
Isaac Clark return to Captain kick-ass
what the tick tock I don't like the
sound of this this guy seems like a
crazy person
you didn't know you could reverse
gravity plating and hammer someone into
the ceiling yeah I did neither until I
try I knew it
I've been alone on a spaceship so much
longer than you have there was a spike
in power usage from environmental
control when the trigger uh I must be
where he's drawing power diamond losing
far from where you are IG here I'll send
you the coordinates I'm definitely not
skipping bench breaks which is what I'm
gonna call them and I definitely need
more my weapons are fine I've got
perfectly upgraded weapons I just need
look at that I'm almost good to go I got
to torque bars and let's cook up a
medium or two and that should do me good
for now I actually I'm doing in pretty
good shape because my new weapon
actually is a lot better in ammo
conservation because it's clips are a
lot larger which is good in a lot of
ways ok back up or go more electricity
traps duh Isaac Clark down out time
ohshit Clark turbo whoa Jesus Christ
volleyballs ah
come on shoot him shoot him shoot him
boom damn
Jesus no get off the ladder Isaac duh
Isaac Clark what a climb on ladder never
allowed to climb on ladders as a kid ah
Isaac Clark
aha finally a chance to use my torque
bar unlocked let's see what's in this
room
I didn't get to unlock the first one
kind of regret it now rotator cuff
module that's not too special
granny wagon like breakdown rotator cuff
modules or some reload press rate of
fire I could use that for my shotgun
here a shotgun is a little Slayer
easy peasy lemon squeezy the game is a
lot more fun when it's not so fresh
kidding whoa couple bullets and a
shotgun just the way my mother tobe duh
Isaac Locke didn't have a mom or a dad I
was born from the Necromorphs the marker
okay enough Isaac Clarke can only handle
so much Isaac Clarke in one day oh my
god hey that's an explosive I saw that
from a mile away
ah you can't hide from me I'm Isaac luck
too bro I mean if there's a way to build
objects on a bench there's got to be a
way to break them down right I would
assume maybe I'm not sure oh look you
know I'm not screwing around uh-huh then
I can't just let you waltz into
environmental yeah I don't want to die
I'm sorry
computer armed explosives
hey I only left you with a few no you
won't actually you will be seeing me
very soon because I'm about to pay you a
visit buddy ah stasis combo come at me
bread Oh one shot
I'm freaking destroying everybody I see
except not that guy because I missed
give me that
thank you Oh big guy boom give me that
Oh detonators suiciders where is he
we're all day I would like to know where
they are thing oh they're way down there
okay
warning oh he's going in a van probably
gonna pop out right next to me no no
he's got where are you come on out [ __ ]
thank your lumps
leapin oh that guy now so big guy
Oh Jett how that friggin hurts
suck on that okay I just gotta I gotta
be a lot more mobile than I am because
I'm I'm letting him get near me and
that's not good for my health
boom Josh duh Isaac Clark back in bad
Mass bad mass nation detected bad ass
bad masturbated all right who else wants
some like the music that's a nice touch
is there anybody else here or am I
supposed to do something oh I'm prize
what the lip the lockdown again I'm an
idiot duh duh Isaac Clark was too
focused on murder where is it
tired is whoa what is this sumbitch
okay I need to get obviously need to
connect the circuits somehow
all righty contamination detected huh
interesting
I see the orange part there I'm not sure
what that means though let me take it
another look at this in my date me a
while I'm not exactly sure what the
hell's going on here okay let me just
try rotating that new come on now don't
be like that how about you uh I'm
grabbed on yeah why don't you do
something okay okay hang on okay it's I
got a line up the like the like edges no
not that
almost got it though ah I see it cuz
this has got that and that lines up
there that doesn't line up there what
dial what am I supposed to do here wait
a minute there's gotta be something else
here what this doesn't make any sense
what the hell I can't be right
ah but these don't line up there what
huh I'll get this puzzle this doesn't
make any goddamn sense
you can't line them all up what the
[ __ ] [ __ ] morning
contamination yeah yeah Oh
quarantine lifted you only got a line up
the center oh okay never mind sir sorry
I'm an idiot that was staring at me ran
the phone in front of the face I should
have guessed that a lot sooner my bad my
bad my bad my bad
ah damn I'm damn I'm dumb but I'm proud
the gun this I'm like why do they need
so many different of these weird puzzles
I mean the the problem with different
puzzles like that is you got to change
up you're changing up the rules of the
puzzle each time I mean it's not bad but
okay I need a stasis in that take that
out take that out and there we go
I just wanted to live that's all I
wanted to live I wanted to live okay
crazy yeah that did the trick
gravity is reading normal again what do
you think is worse buckle dying along
with everyone else right being the only
one who survives looks not the guy that
scares me it's not making a difference
before I do we should be able to make it
the top of the conning tower now Isaac
Edwards is around that's where they'll
find him and his stash yeah hi poor guy
I mean I like I like that old character
I don't know who he is but he it's
characters like that that I think are
richer in terms of who they are I mean I
don't know a lot about any of the other
characters but that particular character
has his whole character explained
through his voice and what he says and
that's pretty hard to pull off but it's
really cool I like it I like that
character a lot
pop goes the neckroll morph you wanna
play that's a leg that is not anything
oh you back up haha Oh dodging a I still
have yet to use my role practically I
mean it's hard to do because I mean I
could I guess assign it to a different
but Holly Jesus back shotgun give me
that
take that no not gonna die from that
that's gonna completely miss you alright
whatever
teach their own am I going the right way
yes I hey they're getting good it
popping up behind me like that they're
getting real good at that and I don't
like it I don't like it at all alright
let's slap this bad boy in my weapon
here I've already got a couple in here
actually you know what I assigned a lot
of C rate of fire I think that's what I
need more let's get the other combo one
in there as well and let's take these
out actually hang on I need to take the
because I got a couple good ones in here
there's reload and damage this one I'm
sorry but how do I take it out how do I
take it out how do I take it out how do
I take it out now whatever doesn't
matter I'm full up on the other one
anyway
so I got the let's put the reload and
rate of fire on the bottom one that's
what I get I'll piss how do I take it
out how do I take it oh whatever
hang on I gotta get more ammo and health
kits make sure that I'm topped off on
those
ha how do I take it out I don't know oh
well it's the little things that make me
angry
alright so I still got one torque bar
left I should be good in case I've found
another room let go I imagine I will
find a wealth of stuff waiting for me
the music's getting a little bit long
here
come on buddy hi Edwards stop being a
dick wait two three three maybe I don't
know I'm going up to some sort of tower
I'm assuming I go up to three yeah hello
is you here
OOP OOP it's not like those were
stopping the Necromorphs from pouring in
anyway so not exactly the best job Bree
oh wow you want me here I am uh oh boy
this guy was obviously quite insane
already lations you found me
kind of stupid ain't I just wanted to
live and now that I'm the only one left
I couldn't give a [ __ ] with all this
time alone I realized it's just like Sam
said I'm a lazy prick who never took one
for the team
well team you can hear me now this one's
for you whoa wait a minute I was right
this whole thing was this guy was 200
years old that corpse is ancient ha ha
ha everything about that was recordings
that's so freaky that is quite weird
quite weird
congratu no I fired it listen to that
hang on that is that is actually very
very clever I like that is so weird
though all right come on
do I even out I don't remember picking
up a key card ah looks like a supply
runs lock god damn it look I guess gotta
go down and up and down and up and down
and up again these optional missions are
actually pretty bulky I'm surprised I
may not hit all of them
I mean I'll try but the game is gonna be
long enough as it is and no I'll hit
them all I like dead space so get ready
for a long series of playthroughs not
that that bothers me lots of content to
bore through and that's what I've been
hoping for
aha O's right there good thing too I
don't exactly have to hunt around for it
I should have dropped off at two first
anyway grimy looking showers any other
artifact me here maybe yep nap nap nap
nap now up we go
why could man why what was the point of
that why did that need to happen I don't
know
oh well questionable game design up
slowly we rise color now we have what is
this open woo
rate of fire clip spare parts medical
support spare parts upgrade sir my
inventory full below no I need one med
kit aha perfect no ah poopy I guess I'll
drop one med kit alright we are full up
that was worth it I think took me a
while but I realize now why we couldn't
be allowed to live uh-huh look if you
found this and you're still alive I
guess I can finally do my part computer
blow all remaining charge
you're such an [ __ ] guy you're such
an [ __ ] nice music though I guess
hello goodbye I love that Wow what the
hell he's able sneak up on me ACK ha ha
I don't even understand where they come
from
come on oh I got a shotgun shells bring
it on a boom a bag a do I need to do I
need to disarm something
oh no I'm free to go that didn't take
long at all why are you thinking I'm in
it to win it and I'm gonna go so far in
my life I never have a big fan of
country but somehow it's very fitting
let's go on to the next nightmare
straight ahead
there are still a lot of those out just
ignore him let's go let's go bye buddy
damn pukers is everywhere mother hovers
they all want a piece of Clark ah we're
through
no no no no I don't think so I do not
think so I am out of here you go suck Oh
get out of here
Scooby right duh Isaac Clark over there
no you [ __ ] he got me you got me so slow
I'm so god damn slow there we go what
the okay it's kidding me hey how about
you go [ __ ] yourself how about you go
[ __ ] yourself I hope this is the right
way ah ha hey Clark running for his life
yep I'm out here [ __ ] all y'all not you
guys yeah I'm headed to the aft section
now and check out that shuttle oh yeah
please [ __ ]
oh yeah it's a piece of [ __ ] all right
but I don't matter I got to find a bench
and drop all this crap there we go got
too much crap in my life all right let
us get ya
lots of spare parts and all that junk
let us upgrade a little bit better with
rate of fire damage
we got reload clip let's replace that
with rate of fire clip get this with
some real of damage and that's reload
wood in McCullen reload rate of fire
that's it alright we are good to go
we're ready to roll we did good
much better I'm sorry guys and it took
me five episodes to realize what I
needed to do to beat the game but I'm
still moving forward I'm back in my dead
space rhythm so thank you everybody so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos set I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye dear before I move forward I
have a key
Oh